this is a review of the iPhone 6s oh
yeah I'm the iPhone 6s plus they look
exactly like the iPhones released a year
ago
you know the phones millions of people
are walking around with these lovely
ladies all have one he's got one hex
this guy's probably got one so what the
heck do all these people have to do with
the new bones
well the iPhone 6 took care of so many
of the complaints people had about their
iPhones especially the bigger screen
in fact the iPhone 6 is almost the
perfect smartphone almost and that's why
we're here to find out if the iPhone 6s
addresses the remaining complaints it's
pretty much universally agreed upon the
number one thing people want in their
smartphone is better battery life that's
why it pains me to say that the iPhone
6s gets barely any more battery life
than the iPhone 6 an iPhone 6s and 6s
plus lasted just as long on my web
surfing test as the previous models
because of the new camera tricks I
actually felt like I was charging the
phone more frequently the real bummer
the new phone is slightly heavier three
marshmallows heavier but the battery
inside is actually slightly smaller
aside from that's great but I get slow
sometimes yeah I've heard that before
but the reason people storms get so slow
now
so much war on them fortunately the
iPhone 6's was built to handle new a9
processor is speedier and there's now
two gigabytes of RAM compared to the
iPhone 6 exporting video was three times
faster and jumping between apps was also
quicker photos even selfies that take up
more space the new live photos are my
favorite thing about the success they
can capture the still photo plus some
live action before and after they're
awesome for reliving fun moments but
they take up two to three times as much
space as an iPhone 6 photo then there's
the very sharp 4k video you can capture
actually captured this entire clip with
the iPhone 6s plus but be careful it
will take up six times the amount of
space as a regular HD video and you'll
need a 4k screen to really take
advantage of it I wish you dare touch
the screen a bit harder
yeah I made him say that and of the
hundreds of people I've spoken to this
week none have said that but they may at
some point the successes most innovative
feature is called 3d touch press hard on
some apps or inside the app and you get
taken to some quick shortcuts that's the
potential to make us much faster on our
phones but right now it doesn't work
everywhere I want it to the people have
spoken and now it's my turn the iPhone
success is a slightly better iPhone than
the sense that's really what the S
stands for if you're gonna buy one make
sure to get one with at least 64
gigabytes of storage as for the other
complaints and battery life we'll have
to see what the iPhone 7 bring why can
you teleport me back to Canada